i'm gonna play a throwback video i don't
know what this is gonna be like but this
is from 1967. okay let's go it's gonna
be horrible
what do you look for in a math oh money
of course
it's very important as long as he's got
money that's the most important thing
there is
i can bear almost anything as long as he
has clean teeth
he needs to have teeth
[ __ ] out there that is the most
uk thing i've ever heard of my life yeah
i'll take anything as long as he still
has his mouth intact
cause you're dealing with that every day
come here give me a kiss and your [ __ ]
look like [ __ ] god damn
i got train wreck up in this 1967 the
standards are different she said money
and there's somewhere about there fresh
and fitter just like
we're going back in time invite her on
the pond
[Laughter]
find this [ __ ] today let's bring her on
and ask her opinions about dating
now i know you grew up
in the 60s think about this
that being said how do you feel about
dating today i look for kindness and
sincerity most of all would it matter to
you over man's ugly
i think it would i mean look still help
but um i think the most thing is
kindness and gentleness i mean
i wouldn't care if he was handsome he
was he wasn't kind he wouldn't appeal to
me
i think personality warmth and affection
for children are the main things she is
faced who
she she she
hey listen yeah i'm not even gonna lie
to you my favorite movies back to the
future so
i see this i'm like hey man
go make my car go back in time let's go
cindy lopper
girls want to have fun
yeah the scientists who doesn't yeah doc
yeah
don't you it's a dog right there
no that's gold goes to her have fun you
know what you can't appreciate
you know what you can't appreciate when
you look at it you're looking at
someone's real face yeah she's 15.
[Laughter]
what about his looks would you mind if
he was very ugly
oh no i don't think so i don't think
looks very good anyway because
the man is too wrapped up in himself
oh i think firstly it's good sense of
humor
personality
kindness like in children
i think things like that when she's
happy she's like that
for sure
oh that's nice
for sure for sure
any crumpets
with
i tea know really to see
interest do you think look so important
sometimes all depends on the man what
about money
money is not important
would you marry an ugly man i've married
one
[Music]
shout out to you my girl yes
i've married i've married one but he's
got money
therefore it
depends
yes
oh [ __ ] train wreck
imagine going through a long day work on
the fact you come home and your wife's
calling you ugly on tv everyone yeah
and that's how you get domestic
you want to do another one yeah let's go
i like this kind of retro stuff that's
funny [ __ ] should husbands help with the
weekend housework it's interesting to
see how different you really thought
about stuff but you know listen to their
answers in regards to what they look for
do you feel there's a big difference
between what they say and then what we
say today
because i thought there was a variety
one woman said money the other one said
kindness
yeah well yeah i i think it's gonna be
the same thing there's gonna be some
people that are gonna be like yeah you
have
it's gonna be diverse yeah i think it's
gonna be diverse the look was crazy
different though the look of course i
mean you can imagine the hair the makeup
but i'm talking about
like if this was today half these girls
would have botox or lip injections yeah
because they didn't have botox back then
partially
partially if it would if both was what
was available back then it would have
been a thing yeah trust it would have
been a thing trust it's just that it was
not there so we can't be like oh my god
my son is so he's so smart he like he he
could take the remote control and choose
his channels i couldn't do it [ __ ] you
didn't have a remote control back then
shut the [ __ ] up
do you not think that the culture we
live in today encourages people to do it
and that back then they would not have
been as likely to do it it would
you think they would if it would have
been if botox was bad then it would have
been because it was all about looks it
was all about having a small waste so
they they were selling the mentality was
there they were selling those i'm
talking like i remember like i'm an old
[ __ ] giza but they they were they
were they were
they were like selling all these
products they were selling all these
products
waste trainers
all these things and stuff called say
and same thing with your do your do have
to be up so that the mentality was there
yeah the mentality on looks was there so
if botox was a thing if it was like a if
it was a a beauty standard also you have
to know that back in the days it was
like all petite and everything and stuff
the thing so it wouldn't be like bbs and
[ __ ] because having a big ass was not a
thing but if it was if it was yeah 100
my point is i don't know if surgeries
would have been a thing and you know the
the question isn't whether or not they
did things to improve themselves look
wise do you not think there is a
difference between like the point where
you start injecting yourself and doing
all that stuff or do you think it's just
do you do you think it's just like
it's a continuous grade it's not like uh
it's not like a cliff where you jump off
and you're in a different style the only
difference is the diff is the technology
how how effective the technology was
because i in 67 all the big girls would
have it wouldn't be a pbl but it would
have been like lipo lipo would have been
the thing but lipo was not available you
just have to be a fat girl big girls
they don't care they don't cry but they
fat
and they stay fat
and that sometimes make them cry because
i was a beauty center back then why are
you gonna say it like that they were
because that i'm talking about i'm
talking 1967.
so
so yeah so let me ask you that right
since you're so old and [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
why
you know your face is your money maker
the first thing that people see and you
have to take care of that i understand
that it's not for everybody it's not
everybody that know how to do it and
know how to take care of their skin well
that's a wonderful timing that you have
here because we have this wonderful
project that i'm using to clear off
everything in my skin and my paws t.h
henley what i would suggest you to do
i suggest you to take and to start with
the level one system it's a box what
kind of products i got in the box i'm
about to tell you right now well first
of all they have a face wash you don't
want to get all in the nooks and
crannies all the pores keep all the
grime out boom they have a moisturizer
as an spf uh 20 in there you don't have
a little protection from the sun they
have instruction with the products that
you're gonna use to tell you when to use
the products how to use the products go
on the link below right now click on the
link below and save 30 off your first
purchase and also you can get a free
gift from th henley i'm just saying if
you wash your booty
wash your beauty
that was genius what do you think is the
difference between women black men and
women today if any there's not much no
not much okay not much whoa audience
right now is your time comment let us
know why is why he's wrong because i
know some of you like no no [ __ ] back
first off they weren't [ __ ] they were
women okay let's let's be appropriate
secondly let's hear them out i don't
think they were very much different
what's different is the standards see
it's the ecosystem right so the the
women are going to be different or not
or think differently or not because of
the men and i don't think that men were
so much different so there's going to be
a variety there's going to be people
that were especially in the uk you you
didn't say it correctly but it's kind of
poetic in a way you said it's an
ecosystem
which is kind of like an echo from the
past echoing today to the present right
it's not a different sound it's just an
echo of the past an echo system
that's not what i meant i meant an echo
system like the link what i'm saying
even when you [ __ ] up ukraine bars no
you know what they call it they call it
crash to create where where where did i
[ __ ] it up
you said ecosystem yeah echo system
oh you talk about my pronunciation [ __ ]
you heard what the [ __ ] i said hold on
you [ __ ] up words all the time about the
echo system who cares
about um
that's not echo
but
i don't give a [ __ ] okay when you say
parameters parameters everyone's like
now i like parachutes too yeah
parachutes parameters same to me i don't
give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] it's not it's not
her criticism i actually enjoy it i know
right even i'm talking to them over
there how do you guys know about that
parameter it's parameters parameters
parameters parameters
i you know why because in french we'll
see
exact amount i just
you just translate i thought all of you
[ __ ] are like it's not like
that how do you say cool [ __ ] say it in
french you don't know french shut the
[ __ ] up
how many languages do you know none
so i'm gonna say parameters if i want to
you're a little hoe
i went i went for i would i would i
would hey it's all good
they were coming for the way you say
words i understand i don't give a [ __ ]
that's a thing yeah yeah and now from
now on i'ma just say words differently
just because because it's to piss you
all off at the end of the day y'all
gonna comment it's gonna it's gonna end
the the the the alligator rhythm uh the
question today a homely one should
husbands help with the weekend housework
how's the [ __ ] that you say to me
i don't know if this guy edited that on
purpose but it was beautiful should
husbands help with the housework this
man turned around like you were
bothering him with the most what the
[ __ ] did you just say
get off my lawn he turned around like
that do you think that husbands should
help with the weekend housework
yes definitely oh why do you say that
because after that you get the booty
that's what i was thinking the weather
i'm 70. you know how she still sucks my
dick
i caught it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i caught it it was falling and i
went
and you can't get up yeah
i know him
he dreams
she looked like she knew a secret
she looked like he she knew a secret i
think she was just off camera like
getting her face right here yeah yeah
yeah
she went i'm not ready or she or she
just got caught she didn't know she was
in the way and they told her but that's
not the way it looked
do you think that husbands should help
with a house house work at the weekends
well that all depends if the wife goes
to work through the week i think she
should help
otherwise i don't i think you should
relax a little bit are you married i am
does your husband go to work i suppose
he does oh yes and you yes oh you both
go to work
so your husband does cooking and that
kind of thing oh yes everything
makes sense makes sense
but i thought traditional housewives you
know i mean back in the day you know
what i mean that's the uk
that's that's what you was australia
australia
reflection of the uk i think that
husbands should help with the weekend
housework
it all depends what chores they've got
to do themselves
how's it organized at your house well i
have four girls and
there's a lot of work to do
yeah okay i thought i was the only one
the way he rolls up on people it's
almost like he's a pickup artist
yeah yeah no but there was no the
problems like don't hey
how do you feel about that that [ __ ]
down don't ever [ __ ] put that [ __ ] in
my face
but but that's what it looks like that's
what it feels like
and the camera is painting as she's
backing up oh i guess that means the dad
can sit down most of the time and no
he's out most of the time she's back
against the wall bro
[Music]
[Applause]
i love this [ __ ] this is awesome to me
do you think that um
she's right in the views that you should
help with the housework i would why
shouldn't we
[Laughter]
ah
yo she looked at that thing like yo she
looked at that thing like he's just
swung he's just flying his penis in the
metro and she's like ah no no put it
away dude yeah certainly all the time
but mine doesn't
she ah
that's what she looks at the camera
no no no no no no no no no that was she
she was about to kill her husband
doesn't matter [ __ ] [ __ ] that's a
message
yeah no i think they should but he don't
it's interesting and billy i'ma [ __ ] you
up when we get home maybe maybe i wasn't
expecting it i was surprised by how like
you know some of them you're probably
just brown-nosing a little bit or just
saying whatever the camera's on but i
was still surprised by how consistently
everyone was like yeah we should share a
bit of the housework you know i'm
married been married for a long time and
we do share i try to help out around the
house or do some of the gardening or do
some of the outside stuff
all of them consistently said that i
believe some might have been lying but i
don't know if it's all of them so i was
surprised to hear how
egalitarian a lot of it seemed back in
the day what are your thoughts some of
them would have been lying today
people lying on tv all the time yeah
yeah i'm doing this and that and that
yeah we ain't doing [ __ ] yeah i mean
tv's on they want to look good that that
is what it is yeah but yeah it was yeah
interesting it was it was just but like
i said people didn't change much i don't
think they have yeah i just feel like
the way that people talk today is much
more extreme though
yes
maybe it's because we're online too but
it's like no no the [ __ ] does this the
man does this that's like
but in the 60s it doesn't sound like
they were really confirming to those
norms that you're mentioning
it was just different
you say it's the same but how is it
different
some people people would say that hey
the man's gonna have to do a bit of the
work you know people would say that yeah
some man you know maybe i have to do a
little bit of the work they would say
that absolutely we have this idea of
what it was in the past and we when i
mean we it's not us as some people have
this idea of uh we have to do this like
back in the days like when it's like
whenever people talk about hip-hop and
be like yo the way people dress the
rapper's dress today is mad weak by it's
mad weak because you know rappers back
in the days it was like you know i mean
it was up it depends where back in the
day you go
70s i've seen some rappers and cowboy
booths and tight letters like
leathers
but yeah that hasn't changed much but
people whenever they refer to the back
in the days they really have this idea
of whatever they saw in the mainstream
or in in the media or how i was
portrayed where that's the people he was
talking to the people not the tv not the
videos not the the not the movies and
stuff like that it was talking to actual
people that was living every day if we
look at the media
of of today
and just the media and later on in life
people just have the reflection of they
look look back and they look okay that's
how everybody was back then no that's
not how everybody is the media that's
that's just a portion of people that put
their stuff out there when you look back
but that's not what the reality of it is
you know i mean not everybody goes on
trips every [ __ ] week and this and
that that's just a reflection of not
everybody goes to dubai that's just a
small portion of people that put it out
there but if you look at the media's
you're gonna think that